i'm amazed that this works as well as it
did this is like so
crazy there's one thing that stands out
to me it's a really common mistake
thanks to vessie for sponsoring today's
episode stick around to the end to get
25
off their brand new everyday move
sneaker hey everybody welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react we're here joined by the
one and only seth rogen hi
you're probably wondering why seth is
joining us on the show i forced myself
on the show and uh yeah i've learned a
lot from watching your show and i think
it's a show that filmmakers uh all
filmmakers could learn from so it's a
pleasure to be here thank you my
goodness you are a very accomplished
producer and director you have
experience
being in the thick of it yeah on all
sides acting with the visual effects
people directing producing well let's
jump into some clips we got some movies
that seth has worked on and been in and
maybe a couple to roast
[Music]
so to start things off i wanted to take
a look at an american pickle because
seth you play both of the main
characters in this movie and that's not
an uncommon thing i mean we've seen that
before with like the parent trap and
lots of other movies but what makes this
movie really interesting is that the
beard that you're wearing you know most
people would just have that be like a
fake beard so you can actually produce
it all at the same time
easily but you guys insisted on having
your beard be real yeah there are
certain things that i just think they
have not achieved in film and a good
fake beard is one of them like you watch
the avengers and the fake beers don't
look good like you could literally have
like the most resources available to a
film and a fake beard just isn't quite
there i feel similarly about like car
green screen driving like yeah i will
watch the most expensive movies and be
like that's not a real driving shot like
they just didn't and it's not for lack
of money it just it's hard to do that
was the thing with me is like i have a
beard in real life a lot of the time so
people know what i look like with a
beard as well
and so i was adamant that we don't use a
fake beard that creates a very
interesting problem because now you have
to shoot everything yeah and then go
back and reshoot it in the exact
pixel perfect way you did to begin with
yes how much time was there between when
you started shooting all the herschel
stuff and then when you had to shoot uh
the bend stuff later basically one day i
switched over we shot it was probably a
month of shooting the herschel stuff and
then i shaved and then a month but it
was weird because we shot the whole
movie twice essentially we were going
back to all the same places so that was
really weird and the seasons changed and
[ __ ] like that as we were filming and so
just like everything looked way
different at times like and so like we
couldn't we just couldn't go back to the
same location so it was hard
[Laughter]
i was often acting to
a nobody or a tennis ball
or someone just looking at me that was
weird because it was supposed to be very
naturalistic but i was not talking to
anybody the hardest thing was tracking
where people are looking and [ __ ] like
that was really hard and oh yeah the
timing i would have beeps in my ear
that were signifying when to pick things
up when to do things so i would be
hearing dialogue i'd be hearing my own
lines that i would be responding to and
then there'd be b b beep and on the
third beep it means he sat down and then
i continue the scene and then i will
hear the beeps and on the third beep it
means he stood up and went over there
and then i'll hear beep beep beep and
throughout the beeps it means he's like
getting up and walking over there and
then the result is like nobody notices
it was so hard sometimes that we would
do like 10 takes to get the timing right
it would just be like great we got to
the point where like no one will think
we did anything
i get it for a lot of this stuff i'm
like okay you just you keep careful
track of where the tripod is placed
where the camera is the corners of the
frame and then you can replicate that
later but there's a couple shots that
kind of confused me i was like wait how
did how did they do that yeah and
one was when you guys were like walking
through the park you guys are walking
next to each other and i was i was like
going through my head like the numbers
are flashing around the screen i'm like
okay you filmed it for real in the park
with you walking and then you had to
film the other u on a green screen and
you had to match it up and track it into
the shot
and then i saw the behind the scenes and
it was just like both of you guys were
on a green screen
well we also did a version with me not
on the green screen oh really okay
probably mostly for reference i'm not
sure what ultimately was used but we did
we did it every which way but out of
everything there was one shot that
literally made my jaw drop and it was
when you're in the forest towards the
end of the movie and you push over a
tree yeah yeah yeah because i was
instantly like okay you're in a location
and there's two of you actually
interacting with a real object
there in the forest so what's your
insight into how that was done we went
back to this same spot a few weeks apart
if you were to just take the backgrounds
of each shot they would be different and
this was like a thing that was built
the reason why i think this shot works
really well in cells that you two are
together is something i didn't realize
until basically just now
i remember you guys pushing on the same
lock
that helps it nicely
for sure very much so
the shoulder hit helps yeah
totally
yep how to get burned how to get burned
how to get burned how to get burned the
wicker man
the bees the bees the bees
killing me won't bring back your goddamn
honey this movie's bat [ __ ] enough yeah
this is all over the place yeah
oh no not the beast
not the beast
[Music]
oh man the tracking job oh that's bad
his skin's ready to look way more
he's like just a boy he doesn't look bad
at all
i don't want to sit in that much makeup
i mean
ah it's like there are aspects that are
really well done but man it's like maybe
motion blur
yes motion blur
they're very crisp those views it's
tough that they're behind the mesh that
probably doesn't make any deal
the tracking on his head like when he
was shaking his head from the side there
like that was like that's not easy to do
and they managed to basically mostly
pull that off for me there's like not
really any contact shadow yeah between
any of the bees in his face there should
have been way more bees yeah he would
have been way more horrific
he's not there's like you know i feel
like you could survive that many bees
probably see that's what like this is a
bummer like neil labute was on set being
like are these bees gonna look real and
the guy was like they'll look great the
trunks they're gonna look really cool
they'll be super scary and then you're
like in the room being like
we can't get any better and they're like
no that's it
oh man
god bless him you know they're trying
out here nicholas cage is getting it is
all exactly an odd man nicholas cage
yeah he was almost the villain in the
green hornet but wanted to play it as a
white jamaican man
and we did not think that was a good
idea
if you enjoy these videos we drop them
every saturday but you know what's even
better is subscribing so you don't miss
them so consider subscribing to our
channel thank you i subscribed these
messages got to be um why am i not
subscribed they really are pushing it
airbags yeah that's so weird is is
anything else missing neighbors i get
asked about this almost more than
anything really yeah because it's one of
the biggest jokes in the movie
oh man yes was that a dummy yeah that's
a i love
dummies
like by the end of shooting it look we
could watch this in playback basically
which is why like i'm amazed that this
works as well as it did because like
literally like you cut to a dummy
and then the dummy slaps back down and
hits the chair i looked at the position
over and over that the dummy hit the
chair in and it was kind of on its side
and then literally i stood on that desk
and just hurled my body down at the
chair like perhaps we're doing a chair
fall like that
no the dummy didn't know the word
a dummy a good dummy goes a long way
dude i love doing this a dummy a dummy
will do a lot okay let's do this man all
right we did it again in the second one
the joke's so nice we did it twice one
two
three and three
these are silly jokes we honestly spend
so much time on them because like if the
physics do not seem real it just isn't a
funny joke like it it's physical comedy
done with visual effects and
that is like a really fine line to walk
and like there's like the scene like
paul blart where like this ostrich is
like kicking you or some [ __ ] and you're
just like oh like no i know the shot
you're talking about he gets kicked by a
horse into a car and that's like the
definition to me of like it that is not
right and like it does not feel real it
feels like a visual effect and that and
that to me is not as funny as when it
feels real in some way
me and evan directed uh this pilot and
the opening of the pilot it was
described as this it was described as
we're in outer space we see like a ball
of energy essentially like
hurtling through the cosmos and and it
was trying to establish
the tone of the show which is very
specific
and very strange it has like a tangible
feel to it
which is not something that that you can
easily get from just computer generating
something or trying to make it photo
real this is 100 computer generation and
that's the thing yeah
i was gonna ask that i was like yeah it
looks like a miniature but i'm wearing
the better it's not all cg and it was
just an easier look to achieve in cg and
if we were trying to make it look
big and expensive
the whole thing was we were like we
can't afford this it just won't look
good like guardians of the galaxy had
come out we were like people are seeing
space in a very well-produced
way these days and we just
literally you're not going to be able to
afford it and i'm a big fan of the
original star trek
okay and
those kind of old space movies and we
were like what if we really just try to
make it look like that and not even try
to make it look real or like guardians
of the galaxy or star wars or one of
these things what if we go like the
complete opposite direction and try to
make it look as analog as humanly
possible and just embrace that and tell
the audience like this is the look of
the show like we bounce between this
like stylized thing to like a more real
thing and we bounce back and forth and
that is what you're getting it's kind of
like a comic book it was something i
look at and i'm very happy with because
like it was leaning into our limitations
and making it a part of the piece and
using that to make it look unique and
special instead of just trying to make
it look like as quote unquote like good
as yeah we could make it look
it's a theme in our work
when i when i take a step
we make people pop
as one of the world's foremost leading
experts in exploiting heads exactly yes
can you break down for me
what goes into a perfect exploding human
being you need to have a real thing
explode and you need way more blood and
guts and [ __ ] than you think much more
than an actual human could ever hold
with this i remember they kept showing
us we would always be like walked out to
a parking lot where it's like okay it's
time to watch the garbage bag explode
again and we'd always be like bigger
bigger bigger and they're just like this
is lower than a human body can hold and
we're like
that is completely irrelevant
that doesn't matter we need 10 times
more than a human body can hold if
that's what looks right on camera and
that's something we're always telling
affects people and probably like one of
the biggest conversations we're always
having is like we're always like we want
the squibs to be huge people do try to
impose reality on you at times not
understanding the bigger picture and i
understand how like if you're an effects
person party you think so it's part of
my job to tell this person like they're
breaking
reality by having
20 times the amount of blood a human
body has but it's also your job as the
filmmaker to at times be like i know i
don't care i don't think me breaking
reality in this way will damage my
vision and i think it'll work fine you
know it'll it'll it'll help the moment
it won't hurt the moment but yeah long
you need a lot more blood than you think
you need to blow it up with real
explosives i love it hey so you may
already know that we've got extended
cuts of the react series on our website
quarterdigital.com and this one is no
different so you can check out this
scene plus some others such as seth
telling us about what it really means to
be a producer on the website it's really
fascinating full episode on quarter
digital.com you get a free two-week
trial we've got other stuff there too
such as son of a dungeon our super super
ambitious d d project anyway check that
out in the meantime enjoy this episode
thank you
tsunami
escape from los angeles
have you seen this of course i have the
surfing scene the serving size that's
got to be the serving scene for escape
that's a cool shot that looks good yeah
that's a good shot
i can't even get behind that some bad
there you go
that's bad oh my gosh
can't be that this is where like you
storyboard a thing and you're like it's
going to be amazing because you look at
the shots and they're the right shots
like they are the right shots
it's over him onto them it's over them
like it's giving you a sense of
geography it's telling the story very
well he's a great director it's shot
right but it's like there's so much
going on in this shot so much it's
ambitious i'd say it's ambitious because
it's like this camera is following along
with these people who are surfing and
the thing about things
whenever you're trying to show someone
do anything on a surfboard other than
just surf on a wave normally you're
you're dude there's that there's that
there's that james bond movie where he's
like
like surfing point break is it yeah
because they're just surfing that's it
they're not trying to they're not
surfing after someone surfing should not
be used as a mode of transportation
trying to get from point a to point b on
a surfboard like i'm leaving for work
there that's where movies that's where
you fail if you're trying to move your
character on a surfboard a circle you go
out to the water you come back that's
what a surfboard does so the reason for
me this scene kind of doesn't work is
how the water actually looks because
it's one of those surf parks what you're
seeing is a very different sort of
dynamic with water they're being hit by
water from behind this is like the
tsunami and yet all the water we're
seeing is literally going the opposite
direction
and it's like you might not be able to
describe what you're seeing but you can
feel it
i could forgive all that okay not for
some of these shots
like this works for me even though it's
like it it's it is coming the wrong way
i it doesn't bug me that much on the
grand scale of things right this is like
so crazy
and there's just like that's the worst
that's the restaurant of the whole thing
the tiny little water squirt in front of
his bicep exactly there is i mean
obviously there's like a million things
going on with this but there's one thing
that stands out to me is a really common
mistake in visual effects and that is
when you have elements you're adding to
your scene like you need to add them in
at the same scale that they were in real
life when you film them so that splash
was like a four foot tall splash it
needs to be a four foot tall splash here
it can't be a three inch tall splash
and it's like i see it with fire i see
it with sparks i see it smoke where they
film it and they try to make it look
like it's a different scale and it just
it never works all right so seth your
name is john carpenter and you've just
been delivered this shot yeah what kind
of notes cameron jiggle i would say uh
that would be i'd say what is the what
are we telling the audience the camera
is mounted on are we telling them it's
on a crane is it being driven in a
little atv with a crane mounted to it
and it's a weird thing i think it makes
it more real when you feel like you
understand how they filmed the scene
because audiences get like oh they would
need to have a camera there it's like
and that makes it seem more real if it
was an image actually being captured by
a camera and then he doesn't look like
he's there i would say like
i'd say could we shoot him out on a real
wave somewhere or something like that
could we throw buckets of water could we
do anything we jettison water behind
actual curt please do we take kurt out
into a parking lot with a hundred garden
hoses and just spray a wall of water up
behind him please that's what i would
honestly try to do is i would try if i
got that shot back i'd be like let's try
to find some in-camera way to reconcile
this moment so
i was looking at that one stunt guy who
was doubling for peter fonda and i was
like he looks familiar
is that tony hawk
what it's tony hawk what that's totally
amazing yeah on the right there that's
tony hawk the taller one yeah i mean i
think he's got like a fake ponytail on
[Music]
[Music]
hey bud
hey buddy
listen i know you're here for seth rogen
he's not here anymore he left okay but
i'm here you got me and that's just as
good right courtesy of today's sponsor
vessy we've got an entirely new sneaker
the everyday move this shoe is where
purposeful design meets technology it
has a patented dymatex material which
has pores so tiny on the top of it that
it keeps water out it is 100 waterproof
this shoe knows what time of year it is
it will keep your feet warm in the
winter and cool in the summer it also
has the v02 midsole which is designed to
deliver all-day comfort and support with
additional energy return with each
stride and it's still the same
incredibly lightweight flexible design
that is basically like your foot is
wearing nothing but socks these sneakers
not only are they inspired by the
silhouette of water the giver of all
life on this planet they also are giving
back to water for the launch of the
everyday move sneakers vesey has
partnered with charity water a
non-profit organization to help bring
clean and safe water to people in the
world who are in most need 100 of
donations will go towards helping end
the world's water crisis so not only
when you buy these shoes are you doing a
favor to yourself you're also giving
water to people step aside everybody
else because vessy's got a brand new
thing in town and if you're interested
in getting 25 off your pair of the vessy
everyday move check the link in the
description below or go to vessie.com
corridor crew for 25
off your order that's vesey.com corridor
crew
it's raining right now do you want
do you want to go outside and play in
the rain
let's go
hey don't show his head
don't show his hat
thank you for joining us for visual
effects artist react i forced myself on
this show it was a pleasure to be here
i'm glad i did it was fun talking to
these guys about visual effects and my
own work which is probably my favorite
thing to talk about in general so uh
thanks for giving me the opportunity
when seth says he forced himself upon us
what he really meant was
i wrote and then deleted the hey do you
want to be in the show about five or six
times
and then i was like can i be on your
show
just alone in my garage making vases
thank you so much for shedding light on
a bunch of your stories and sharing it
with us thank you for having me a
pleasure i've loved it i'm not leaving
we got a guillotine right there for you